very good morning you're watching
sunrise live from Westminster this
morning because of course it is a budget
day Philip Hammond expected to deliver
an upbeat statement when he outlines his
first budget as Chancellor later this
lunchtime it's coming up at 12:30
firstly this morning just hours before
that budget the government was dealt
another blow in its attempts to get the
brexit bill through Parliament the
government defeated in the House of
Lords for a second time last night
this time over demands for a meaningful
parliamentary vote on the final brexit
deal while following that vote the prime
minister sacked Lord Heseltine as a
government adviser over his part in the
brexit rebellion and Lord Hesseltine
joins us now live from central London
good morning @tu mr. Hesseltine their
vote in the Lord's cost you your job in
fact to cost you five jobs you have five
roles in your advisory capacity to the
government was it worth it it was
inevitable that I did what I believed to
be right the whole European debate is
the transcending issue of our time you
want to realize that I have walked
through the lobbies with one
conservative Prime Minister after
another arguing that Britain's interests
in Europe are inextricably linked our
self-interests that's it and so I'm not
going to change my mind now and the
issue of very simply in the House of
Lords was about Parliament about the
sovereignty of parliament every single
national parliament in the other 27
countries of the Union are going to get
a vote on the deal I think that it's
important particularly because of the
very considerable uncertainties that we
set out now that the British Parliament
the custodian of our sovereignty has an
effective role to play in a final deal
that's what we were talking about and
voting for and
I believe that was the right thing to do
there just comes a time in life when
party politics is secondary to your own
deeply held convictions about the
national interest
well the brexit secretary David Davis
had said that the Lord's is trying to
frustrate the process rather than help
it the likelihood is that this amendment
will go back to the Commons next week
and be overturned MPs have been promised
that they will be part of the
conversation in these EU negotiations
but the Prime Minister doesn't want to
have to keep coming back to the Commons
every time she tries to strike part of
the deal if they can understand that why
can't that House of Lords this is about
getting the process done quickly and
efficiently well it's not as simple as
that is it
why if all these other national
parliaments can be involved should as
not be and the Prime Minister has
already herself said that Parliament
will be involved so we merely say well
put it on the statute book and then
everybody is quite clear what the
position will be I find it extraordinary
that our Parliament should be treated in
a subordinate way to the other 27
Parliament's of Europe is this not
weakening the Prime Minister's position
because she has essentially said to the
EU I'm going to offer you a
take-it-or-leave-it deal if she comes
back to Parliament to have a meaningful
conversation about it she's not going to
go back and say actually Parliament
don't like it so we need to negotiate
again because the EU will then try and
give the UK even worst ever well you see
I take a totally different view the
Europeans know of Britain's view about
Europe we've always been on the skeptic
side that's why I do go vetoed as a bit
early because he didn't think we were
psychologically up for the journey so
that was a first step then we try to
compete with them because we wanted free
trade so we have the European free trade
area and that fell apart because the
members of it all wanted to join the
European Union and so I take the view
that if the Europeans believe there is a
genuine wish in this country to find a
better Accord they're more likely to
resist the calls which are already there
in Europe to punish us because that they
will say and they are saying look you're
not going to get a deal as good as the
one you've now got and we can't give you
one because if we do other countries
will say well why not us so they will
remain united but I think that if
Britain is seen to be interested in a
constructive relationship and that's
what the House of Lords knows I think
implying in its vote yesterday we're
more likely to get a sympathetic hearing
in Europe not less talking about a
constructive relationship but have you
met with the Prime Minister Theresa May
about brexit as a senior government
adviser have you been in front of her to
talk about this I I haven't I don't
think I've ever met to resume I we may
have been in the same sort of collegiate
circumstance years and years ago but
I've certainly not met her over recent
years it was a senior government adviser
I should meet you you know well I'm just
I'm just asking you in a role as senior
government advisory not just one job but
five advising the government you've
never actually met yes but I think I
think you know but but I think you have
to recognize that I'm really a sort of
left over from David and George they
were the ones who brought me back in and
it was under them that most of this work
although it's fair to say that it has
spread under two visa may I was meant to
be in Swansea today helping the SEC
State for Wales and I've been looking at
the industrial strategy which resumes
interruption I'm just trying to try to
understand this because obviously as a
senior government adviser you would
assume that you would have met the prime
minister and as somebody who would be
known to be leading the rebellion in the
House of Lords against the brexit bill
you think that you might have sat down
across a table from each other and
talked about your differences well I
don't in any way criticize her for this
she
got a man-sized job to do and she's very
busy I've been working very
constructively with three different
sections of states in the sort of the
Twilight world of politics doing the job
that I know how to do best it's a woman
size job now but I'm just trying to get
to the bottom of how you can have a very
real I realize because I said it I knew
you wouldn't be able to resist that well
it is in social worlds they load
hesitate that yeah I know you're
perfectly right I find myself chastised
by you and your partner in the
friendliest but is the friendly social
way but the fact is that I said I told
the Chief Whip in the Lord's last week
what I was going to do and I set it out
in pretty clear language in a Sunday
newspaper so nobody would have been
surprised that that given the views I
hold and the Prime Minister for whom
I've worked that I believed but his
self-interest is the prime overriding
responsibility of individual members of
parliament and therefore that's why I so
voted